خطاب الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين حمل
رسائل كثيره لعل ابرزها اشاره الى وجود
انقسام داخلي بوتين توعد بمطارده ومحاكمه
من سماهم بالخونه كل الذين اختاروا خيانه
روسيا يجب ان يحاسبوا امام القانون
في الان ذاته مؤسس مجموعه فاغنر وجه
اسلحته الكلاميه اتجاه وزير الدفاع الروسي
سيرجي شويغو ورئيس الاركان متهم اياهما
بمحاوله تدمير قوته وحرمان مقاتلي
المجموعه من الذخائر فالخطوه ترقى الى
الخيانه العظمى يقول زعيم فاجنرالونه
[موسيقى]
حكايه الانقسامات في روسيا ليست وليده
اليوم وزير الدفاع سيرجي شويغو اختفى في
اكثر الايام المستعره بعد بدايه الحرب
العام الماضي ولمده اسبوعين تقريبا قبل ان
يظهر من جديد حينها قيل ان اختلاف موقفه
مع رؤيه بوتين ابعده عن الساحه
القصه لا تنتهي هنا الرئيس الشيشاني
الموالي لموسكو رمضان قديروف سبق وفتح
النار ايضا على قاده الحرب الروس سبتمبر
الماضي بعد الحمله العسكريه المضاده من
الجانب الاوكراني وقتها طالب بتغيير
استراتيجيه الحرب احداث تطفو على السطح
رغم ان بوتين يلوح دائما بورقه التوحد
خلفه لكنه لم يستطع ان يخفي جبل
الانقسامات بلال البجدين العربيه